d'abord on va regarder ces images
tournées hier par tf1 à kaboul un homme
les interpelle dans la rue pour demander
à pouvoir être rapatriés regardez nous
évitons la route de l'aéroport trop
risqué ces deux hommes on revient
justement ils ont des passeports
allemand il cherche à monter dans l'un
des derniers avions militaires mais
comment faire de gorée une ancienne et
on ne sait plus comment faire vous
pouvez prendre la route pour sortir du
pays haut et comment ils ne nous
laissent pas y aller la frontière
encore une fois passé à temps nous
supplient de les aider oui oui j'ai
votre numéro messieurs nos peurs mur
voilà alors des images comme ça il y en
a des milliers
on hamm est avec nous ce soir toute la
famille est encore en afghanistan et n'a
pour le moment pas pu être rapatriés en
france d'ailleurs ahmed c'est pas ton
prénom sinon c'est j'ai essayé de cacher
mon identité pour protéger ma famille
qui sont toujours là bas pourquoi tu
pourquoi tu parce que en fait
aujourd'hui tout ce que je veux dire
c'est la vérité c'est rien ne les a pas
de mensonge est rien du tout donc je
veux dire que la vérité pour que le
monde entier sache ce qu'est ce qui se
passe en afghanistan dans ce moment-là
qu'est ce qui se passe justement voilà
en fait je vais vous raconter un peu le
soir si vous voulez bien sûr moi je suis
arrivé en france en 2014 d'accord j'ai
quitté le pays à 13 ans pour des raisons
financières et aussi que je voulais
faire des études absolument j'adorais
aller à l'école et c'est donc quand je
suis arrivé en france j'ai été placée
dans un foyer où il était suivi par des
éducateurs etc etc je peux aller au
collège je fais 4ème et 3ème ensuite à
l'essai de troisième but mon brevet le
cfj et c'est donc ensuite j'ai été
placée dans un lycée ap j'ai fait
l'essai dans un lycée j'ai fait ci
appelait de sécurité à l'issue de ce
genre les trois meilleurs élèves de cp
et partez en bac pro direct bac pro
sécurité donc j'ai fait le meilleur des
classes avec 17 de moyenne générale donc
je peux aller en directement bac pro et
l'ani dans l'année dernière j'ai eu mon
bac avec mention bien et aussi pendant
cette année je préfère l'aider
la formation pompier volontaire etc etc
et et votre votre famille toute votre
famille toi en afghanistan faut pas où
ils sont a en fait toute ma famille en
fait ils sont jamais venus en france
sauf que moi j'ai quitté le pays tout
seul d'accord et ça en fait mes parents
en vie dans les montagnes moi
personnellement ma famille on avait
envie dans les montagnes vous craignez
pour leur vie aujourd'hui vous avez peur
vous avez des nouvelles ou pas du tout
va bien sûr je parle tous les jours et
encore les réseaux et ses rangs pour
appeler à un plus bas de sap etc quelle
est la situation là bas en ce moment
c'est très tendu donc il ya des morts
tous les jours il ya des encore les
attentes on le voit ici en france ou si
malheureusement on voit pas tout ce qui
se passe il disait par rapport à des
morts qu'est ce que s'est passé à
l'aéroport et à deux trois jours je
prends ils ont pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé en fait il ya eu beaucoup plus de
morts que
tout ce qu'on voit en france en fait ils
disent à 60 personnes etc c'est plus de
400 personnes moi et j'ai pas plus de
blessés et c'est donc
et aujourd'hui à quoi à quoi elle
ressemble leur vie à ces cyanobactéries
en fait c'est à dire
là bas en afghanistan en ce moment et a
appuyé de droits de l'homme les familles
n'ont aucun droit 0 doit donc juste pour
dire genre les familles n'ont même pas
le droit d'aller au magasin s'acheter
des maquillages d'accord pour se
maquiller dur juste les gens mais pas le
droit d'aller au magasin pour ce acheter
des habits ils sont obligés de porter
des habits traditionnels et aussi le
truc comment il s'appelle on l'appelle
tchadri la colle ou les trucs car voilà
je suis pas là pour comme si un autre
truc c'est pas pareil mais mekhissi
obligatoires les deux femmes doivent
porter les familles n'ont pas le droit
de travailler moi j'aimerais bien qu'un
jour on reçoit une femme afghane ici
pour que même ils disent
qu'est ce qui se passe là bas en
afghanistan par an aussi aujourd'hui je
dis en tant qu on va dire oui c'est un
homme pourquoi on n'invite pas une femme
ici pour dire à maman ta maman aller là
bas bien sûr ma famille ensuite j'ai mes
soeurs mes frères et mon père ma mère il
souffre en ce moment qu'est ce qu'ils
disent en fait ce qu'ils ont comme 3 en
fait ils sont bloqués à la maison et
peuvent pas aller dans les villes pourra
faire les courses et que c'est à la
maison ils ont peur bien sûr si l'apport
h 24 donc c'est pas une folle c'est un
enfer en fait ils veulent être rapatriés
se bat pour les rapatrier en france
aujourd'hui comment tu te bats pour les
rapatrier en confiance je ferai tout
pour que ma famille soit en sécurité qui
vivent dans un pays comme la france un
pays de liberté on a des droits on a des
en a les libertés de de s'exprimer
comment vous on a de la chance
aujourd'hui en france avec on aime
beaucoup de droit et on y lire dessus ce
que de faire ce qu en vous et on a
beaucoup de chance que la france est et
aident aujourd'hui les pays étrangers
comme l'afghanistan etc par exemple
alors et que au niveau de financièrement
on est en france comment dit on est bien
placé et ayant pour vous permettre de
faire certaines choses que l'art en
afghanistan c'est impossible de le faire
répond